non-minimalists
i think first let's talk about uh the
tool
that's something that really stood out
with me
in the social dilemma i think it was
tristan who said we look at this thing
like it's a tool
but a tool sits around right and it
waits patiently for you to use it
yeah where social media is constantly
demanding something from you yeah so
it's
not that it still can't be used as a
tool bingo
but i think that sometimes we
i don't know we make an excuse well well
it's just a tool that we use
yeah but the but the question is is are
we using it or is it using us
yeah i think we're here here's what i've
i'm speaking to myself here when i say
you i want you to
be clear about that if you have social
media on your phone you're being played
it's that song oh yeah and and so i know
we're going to talk about some
strategies
and some nuances but there are two
things that i want you to get out of
this episode if you stop it right after
this
number one take all social media off
your phone if you can and if you can't
take all personal
social media off your phone i'll make
that distinction there are business
reasons we can get in that probably
during the maximum episode we'll talk
about
whether or not social media is actually
beneficial for business and how it might
be
how it might not be as well so that's
the first thing
and the second thing is what our friend
cal newport calls the four-year rule
so uh or the fourier if you live in a
nice
palatial estate uh i don't have either i
have a very tiny hallway when you walk
into
my apartment i have a junk drawer though
as soon as you walk in
it's in my kitchen which is attached to
that hallway there
and that's where i keep my phone now
it's not that i never use my phone when
i'm at home i certainly do but
when i do want to use it i go and
grab the phone out of the junk drawer
there's a little friction
yeah creating that friction and even
then
i don't have social media apps on my
phone i also don't have email on my
phone
that that's a choice and then it what
what's happening i'm turning it back
into
the tool that it was intended to be yeah
if steve jobs was in the social dilemma
very briefly
yeah and he certainly didn't intend for
this to be what it is today
yeah a distraction machine that is with
you in perpetuity
he was trying to merge a palm pilot with
a ipod
with a flip phone basically uh so that
you had all of this and you had a little
mini computer in your your pocket
the intention was never to curate your
attention
to cultivate your attention as many
hours as possible
in order to sell you advertisements yeah
he liken it to like a bicycle for your
mind or something right
it kind of reminds me it makes me think
about like when we're talking about this
being a tool and we think about
what actually is coming from this
experience of using this tool i feel
like it reminds me of like having an
amazon echo that tells you you're not
good enough
you know like it's like a tool that like
kind of assaults you
like in the middle of the day like it
kind of has an impact on your mind that
you wouldn't necessarily expect versus
like a hammer like
if you don't touch it nothing really
happens like it just sits on a table but
like social media is like a hammer that
comes up and hits you in the face
yeah like if you if you respond to it in
the way that it's designed for you to
respond to it
well let's talk about that tool because
i think that a
smartphone can be a tool and it can also
be
a a bludgeon in a way where it becomes
this
it becomes a hammer that grows legs and
chases you around the place right
and you're like and so i think that the
tv was never
much of a tool right and and so we
recognized it
we there's even euphemisms for the boob
tube or whatever right like
it's we we recognized that like that's
where i'm going to go
veg out we even use this terminology
like i'm a vegetable
standing in front of this like i'm not
animated now
now we veg out at a red light exactly
now we veg out in a waiting room
right we've removed these interstitial
zones
the waiting rooms the red lights these
these the walks that we would take
without the earbuds in or whatever
where we would have time we'd make time
for boredom we'd make time for
ourselves uh we we'd make time to be
alone with our thoughts to sort of
yeah yeah remember with the old pcs you
would
defrag them do you remember this yeah
and so like you have to run like a
defragging sequence on a computer in
order to like keep it
uh running smoothly and i feel like
that's where those interstitial zones
that's what they gave us was a sort of
defragging moment at the red light at
the
the airport lobby where you you didn't
have
access to constant contact and
and therefore people can constantly
contact you i mean now
if i have social media on my phone and i
even if i don't have the notifications
turned on there's the pool to say
did someone at me did someone like my
tweet how many
retweets did i get how many shares do
you whatever it is on facebook like
uh there are all of these these sort of
metrics that were we're chasing
and we're chasing the wrong thing i mean
i think that's the craving
you know the the the buddhist cult the
four truths but one of them is
is craving and i think that is more
pronounced
than ever
you